the most annoying group of people to deal with as a fat person on the internet
it's not like the dude bros making fun of me and calling me fat in my comments
it's not Ed Twitter taking my videos and making me fatsp0
making fun of my body and everything about me
so that they can starve themselves and not look like me
no it's neither of those
the group that is most annoying and irritated is the morally superior
anti fat activist that takes fat people's content from TikTok
cut it up upload it to **Youtube**
making money off of our face
our content our
our movement because either they were fat and hate themselves
are currently fat and hate themselves
or just hate fat people in general
I have had so many of my videos taken and put on the internet
to be made fun of by a group of people that I don't know
that doesn't follow
and every single one takes my arguments in the worst light possible
and makes me seem like I'm crazy
like I don't know what I'm talking about
like you know I'm
I'm making everything up and then like
search through your videos and try and like
point out inaccuracies to look for some kind of proof that like
fat people are all lying up being happy about themselves
they're all lying up being content in their body and like
there's literally no room for nuance with that
and they all think that they're the good guy
that's the crazy
they make these videos
take people's content out of context
post it to a hostile audience and still think that they're the good guy
that's the thing that's the most frustrating
cause like they think that they're in the right
like you are a villain
you are a bad person
leave me the heck alone